if you could give one teas about what's
to come on the show what would you say
there's going to be some steamy scene
strictly let's be honest sure everyone
in the world is dating someone's son so
let's just keep it real Billy and I are
turning up the heat she needs to stop
[__] him MILF Manor brings together
eight hot moms and their single Sons
into one dating pool and I cannot wait
to talk about this with two of my
favorites Kelly and Joey joining us now
how you guys doing good how are you good
I'm ready to connect with somebody who
doesn't really care how old I am how did
you feel like you were portrayed did you
like what you saw so far oh I definitely
like what I saw I mean I was just being
myself the whole time so I dig it yeah
I'm unapologetically who I am all these
women look amazingly hot but they're not
me yes you are so much fun thank you
when you met the other moms what was
your first impression of them I thought
they were they were beautiful we all
look so different and so obviously we're
going to attract different men so
somebody that's interested in like Bola
probably wouldn't be interested in me so
I thought this is going to be easy so
whoever likes wands I have it in the bag
yeah well some people seem like more
receptive to the experiment While others
like Charlene were more like I don't
know like do you feel like some of the
other Moms come out of their shells as
time goes on yes definitely who
surprised you the most I would say Paula
from the beginning to the end how did
you feel you watched back the first
episode she I feel like has the most to
say about Kelly I don't get Kelly very
well she needs to do something to bring
the attention to her and I don't think
that's nice because you don't need to
always be the center of everything I
love her so it didn't bother me I
actually laughed I thought it was
hilarious let's back it up to just like
the production time so what are you told
we were told we were going to go on a
dating Retreat and Joey would have a say
in who I'm dating and I thought that's a
great idea you know for my kids to meet
somebody I'm dating I knew they were
going to be younger no clue on the age
yeah I thought I was going to be be like
more of like a spectator mode type thing
so I would like to date my mom yeah like
give her advice to like other guys and
like yes or no on the guys that she
likes or dislikes did you know you were
gonna be dating oh I I had no clue I'd
be dating they were like you're okay
you're gonna date these very attractive
older like but they're older women like
what did you think are we receptive I
mean I was down for whatever you know
but I thought I was just telling my mom
who to date which it's hard to do
anyways she dates whoever so the curtain
Falls you see your sons there what did
you think I thought it was a joke
I was like why are you here you need to
go somewhere and then not only that
you're like sharing a room to the point
where it's like if one of you wants to
hook up you have to tell the other one
put a sock on the door I'd definitely be
the one leaving because there ain't no
way I'm kicking my mom out of her room
did you feel like oh like I thought I
was gonna be on a dating show and now
I'm in some weird Stanford Prison
experience man I thought there was gonna
be like 30 hot young guys coming out and
I was gonna pick you know you and you
and I thought I was gonna really get to
pick a whole like five moms against 30
guys yeah
that would have probably been a lot more
interesting but it was definitely a big
twist for all of us Joey did you have
time to bond with the other guys before
you kind of entered the show or you were
just meeting them for the first time too
just meeting them for the first time
it's a lot of different personalities to
try to get used to what were your first
impressions of everybody well my first
impression of Jose it was like a
Suavemente type of guy like he just
brings that type of feel and I really
like Jose because he's real whenever he
speaks there's this super hot guy named
Jose and he seems like a safe bet
because he's very family oriented you
can see he's like tied to his mom's hips
some of the other guys and they kind of
more Hollywood type stuff and then you
have to be like you guys are all gonna
try to get with my my mom
like I knew which guys like from the
start we're gonna be good for my mom and
which guys were going to be just
terrible for my mom yeah because you had
a reaction to Ryan the first night and
you were like I'm gonna like put the
stop I had to put this stuff to it come
on I know my mom wouldn't hold back so
it was only me just oh my God it was
only me there just to keep her on the
down low oh come on not a night one
Apollo initially seems like very against
the idea of you and Jose getting
together Kelly is not the type of girl
for Jose I'm 100 sure so she's not gonna
get anywhere with Jose never is there a
lot of that kind of tension going on
through the season oh yeah did you feel
that way over Joey with anything no not
once we kind of like when we were in
group settings we kind of weren't tied
to each other's hip he let me do my
thing I let him do his thing and we were
there to meet new people and get to know
them and see if we could you know
connect on a romantic level I wasn't
there to go make friends with Paula or
any other woman that's not why I was
there I'm not here to make friends no
and strictly let's be honest sure
everyone in the world is dating
someone's son so let's just keep it real
is there anyone on the show that you
were like I would absolutely not let
Joey date this person no because I know
him so well I already knew that he would
make a good decision on his own I raised
him yeah just a tease going ahead were
there a lot of hookups
I mean I guess you'll just have to wait
and see yeah I got my my eyes on some of
the women
is there like a game aspect or is it
like do people get like voted off or
anything they do have different
challenges yeah we played a lot of
challenges the challenges are a lot of
fun and it's gonna be fun to watch
because there's some crazy challenges
that we do yeah crazy out of the gate we
get the
Absolution down
[Laughter]
my mom didn't even get to me on her
touching Channel thank God because it
would have been a little weird I know
some of them are like that's Ryan
they just knew felt like some were
cheating too I don't know
what did you learn about yourselves but
also each other as a result of doing
this show one of the main things I
learned about myself is it forced me to
be very vulnerable and where I felt that
was more of like a weakness it really
showed me it's a sign of strength
because there's a lot of things that go
on in the show where we had to be very
vulnerable with how we're feeling and
vocal and you know and that's hard to do
real relationships are created
interesting this isn't like an act I'm
not an actress Kelly you have six kids
was everyone receptive to episode one of
milk Manor yes they were well and you
sat with your siblings well yeah almost
everyone was together yeah my oldest
daughter is in Dubai so she was watching
from Dubai which is amazing and they're
just so excited and they know they know
us obviously so well in how we interact
with one another and I'm always been
like a very open free-spirited mom she's
disco mommy
um Disco mommy I'm Kelly I'm 50 years
old and my Alter Ego is Disco mommy they
know that about me and so there's not
like a lot of pressure that I put on my
children I want them to enjoy their life
and have fun yeah and I don't really
take a lot of things serious in life
it's too short so you must have like
learned a lot about yourself and dating
in this oh yeah all the women taught me
a lot of different things to like know
about dating because I I honestly knew
nothing and like they've been through so
many relationships and like they just
know and like I knew nothing so I was
just going in like a dick like a deer
and headlights yeah
among the two of you who was more on
board with the experiment probably me
well I mean I was on board it was
definitely at work he wasn't like what
the heck yeah I knew you were for surely
going in and college blazing
I was more just like go with the flow do
whatever and I'm not desperate I just
like you know younger guys yeah I feel
like you just lean into whatever
experience you're in what did you feel
like the social reaction just outside of
people you knew honestly I don't read
social I don't read anything I don't
really care what people think I love
that you know what what other people
think about you is none of your business
no I don't really care do you do you who
makes out with more people
definitely her who causes more drama I
probably was I feel like maybe more
people were coming after me which
created some drama who among you was the
better wing woman or wingman oh I really
helped you one time yeah yeah yeah yeah
she definitely helps me I can't tell you
what a lot but yeah I definitely when it
came into certain things she helped me a
lot what's the best dating advice Kelly
that you can bestow I say just be
yourself you know just be yourself and
if you're connecting with somebody just
go with it but it's really hard to fake
yourself and then try and create a
relationship out of that what's your
number one red flag negativity if you
want someone speaks and they pick up on
it real quick yep and I won't be around
it have you learned what yours are
what's your biggest red flag oh yeah a
liar a dirty little liar been lied to it
too many times I don't like it so that's
how that's what I thought yours was too
you hate liars too yeah but I really
just don't like negative people yeah if
you could give one tease about what's to
come on the show what would you say
there's going to be some steamy scene
steamy I don't know a bunch of craziness
is about to happen and you didn't know
it was called MILF Manor right I
promised you I thought it was gonna be
like dating Mrs Robinson yeah yeah and I
thought that was a sexy so the preview
comes out and you're like it's called
MILF Banner yeah I had to break that to
my two youngest children when they got
home from school uh Hey guys
um just want you to know let me tell you
I didn't name the show
you're gonna learn a new word today oh
God I can teach younger men a lot of
things what are the things
I don't know if I can say that on TV
[Music]